cheer star
jerry harris has been arrested
on thursday the u.s attorney's office of
the northern district of illinois
confirmed the news to e.t
revealing the former navarro college
cheerleader was arrested in chicago on
thursday
and charged with production of child
pornography
according to the criminal complaint
harris allegedly contacted an underage
boy on social media
and repeatedly enticed him to produce
and send
sexually explicit videos and photographs
of himself the complaint
also alleges that the minor victim
informed harris during their initial
online encounter
that he was 13 years old on monday
et reported that harris was under
investigation by the fbi for
allegedly soliciting sexually explicit
photos and sex from minors
and at the time a spokesperson for
harris told et
that the cheer star disputes any claims
against him
quote we categorically dispute the
claims made against jerry harris
which are alleged to have occurred when
he was a teenager
we are confident that when the
investigation is completed
the true facts will be revealed however
according to the criminal complaint
during an interview with law enforcement
that same day
harris allegedly admitted to
investigators that he had asked the
underage boy for sexually explicit
photos through snapchat
the federal investigation is still
ongoing
and e.t has reached out to harris
harris's former employer varsity
and navarro college for comment